>> I THINK HISPANIC VOTERS
ACROSS THE COUNTRY CARE ABOUT
THINGS THAT EVERYBODY CARES
ABOUT.
THEY WANT PROS PAIR FOR
THEMSELVES AND FOR THEIR
CHILDREN -- PROSPERITY.
THEY WANT LOW TAXES.
THEY WANT TO BE SAFE IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES.
I THINK IT’S APPARENT THAT THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY IS ADDRESSING
THOSE ISSUES, NOT ONLY AT THE
CITY LEVEL BUT CERTAINLY AT THE
NATIONAL LEVEL AND IT’S
RESONATING.
MARIA: THAT WAS THE MAYOR OF
MIAMI, FRANCIS SUAREZ ON THIS
PROGRAM LAST MONTH ON HISPANIC
VOTERS FLOCKING TOWARDS THE GOP.
HE WAS PROVEN RIGHT ON TUESDAY
WHEN REPUBLICAN MAYRA FLORES WON
A SPECIAL ELECTION IN TEXAS,
34th DISTRICT, WHICH HAS
BEEN DEMOCRAT FOR MORE THAN 100
YEARS.
FLORES MADE HISTORY AS THE FIRST
CONGRESSWOMAN ELECT TO BE BORN
IN MEXICO.
HER SIGNALS DIVERSIFICATION OF
THE GOP BUT POTENTIAL OF A RED
WAVE IN NOVEMBER.
THE CONGRESSWOMAN ELECT IS
EXPECTED TO BE SWORN IN THIS
UPCOMING WEEK, EARLY IN THE
WEEK.
FIRST MAYRA FLORES IS JOINING ME
RIGHT NOW.
CONGRATULATIONS TO YOU.
THANKS FOR BEING HERE.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME.
FIRST HAPPY FATHER’S DAY TO ALL
THE AMAZING FATHERS OUT THERE
AND SPECIAL HAPPY FATHER’S DAY
TO MY FATHER AND AMAZING HUSBAND
AS WELL.
MARIA: ABSOLUTELY.
AND MINE AS WELL.
SO YOU FLIPPED A SEAT IN A 84%
HISPANIC DISTRICT THAT HAS BEEN
DEMOCRAT-RUN FOR 100 YEARS.
WHAT CHANGED?
>> WELL, TO BE HONEST WITH YOU
SOUTH TEXAS HAS ALWAYS BEEN
CONSERVATIVE.
WE’RE ALL ABOUT FAITH, FAMILY,
AND HARD WORK, BUT THAT IS WHO
WE ARE.
THE DEMOCRAT PARTY TOOK US FOR
GRANTED, FELT ENTITLED TO OUR
VOTE, MAKING THE SAME PROMISING
OVER AND OVER AND NOTHING
HAPPENED.
HONESTLY I WAS FED UP.
WITH THE WHEN WHY I DECIDED TO
RUN AND OF COURSE THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY IS INVESTING IN SOUTH
TEXAS.
THAT HELPED US SIGNIFICANTLY
GETTING THE FUNDING OUT THERE TO
THE ENTIRE DISTRICT TO BE ABLE
TO TELL THEM THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY IS FIGHTING FOR THEIR
VALUES.
MAYRA FLORES IS FIGHTING FOR
THEIR VALUES, VALUES WORTH
FIGHTING FOR.
MARIA: PRESIDENT BIDEN WON YOUR
DISTRICT BY 13 POINTS IN 2020.
YOUR HOUSE IS A BORDER AGENT.
WE TALK ABOUT THE WIDE OPEN
BORDER ALL THE TIME.
IS THIS THE MAIN ISSUE FOR THE
HISPANIC VOTER?
WHAT CAN YOU TELL US ABOUT THE
HISPANIC VOTER AND WHAT YOU’RE
EXPECTING IN TERMS OF VOTES COME
NOVEMBER?
>> WELL THE MAIN ISSUE IS
INFLATION.
IT IS THE COST OF LIVING.
EVERYONE IS EXTREMELY PISSED
OFF, ANGRY AT THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION BECAUSE OF
INCREASE OF GASOLINE, GROCERIES,
OF MEDICATION.
THAT IS HURTING THEM
TREMENDOUSLY, NOT ONLY HERE IN
SOUTH TEXAS BUT IN THE ENTIRE
COUNTRY.
OF COURSE THE BORDER CRISIS IS
SOMETHING WE SEE HERE RIGHT
BEHIND OUR BACKYARDS.
IT IS NOT SOMETHING WE NEED TO
BE TOLD BY THE NEWS.
IT IS SOMETHING WE’RE SEEING
HERE EVERY SINGLE DAY.
FOR ME, I CAME HERE WHEN I WAS
SIX YEARS OLD, I WAS BLESSED TO
COME HERE LEGALLY, BUT I DON’T
WANT MY EXPERIENCE TO BE A RARE
EXPERIENCE.
I WANT MORE CHILDREN LIKE MYSELF
TO BE ABLE TO COME HERE TO THE
UNITED STATES LEGALLY AS WELL
AND BIDEN ADMINISTRATION’S
POLICIES ARE ONLY HURTING
IMMIGRANTS, HURTING THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
BECAUSE OF HIM, WE HAD, WE HAVE
AN INCREASE OF CHILD TRAFFICKING
IN THIS COUNTRY AND THIS IS ALL
ON THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION AND
GONZALEZ WAS PART OF THE PROBLEM
AS WELL IN SOUTH TEXAS.
MARIA: I SAW IT MYSELF WHEN I
WAS ON THE GROUND AT THE BORDER,
REFERRING TO WHAT YOU’RE TALKING
ABOUT IN TERMS OF THIS CHILD
TRAFFICKING.
IT IS JUST A DEVASTATING STORY.
I WANT TO TALK ABOUT
IMMIGRATION, LEGAL IMMIGRATION.
LET’S TAKE A SHORT BREAK.
YOU’RE MARRIED TO A BORDER
PATROL AGENT AS I MENTIONED.
HE IS ON THE FRONT LINES OF THIS
CRISIS EXPLODING IN YOUR
BACKYARD, RECORD 239,000
MIGRANTS APPREHENDED LAST MONTH.
THAT IS NOT INCLUDING THE
GOT-AWAYS.
WE WILL TALK SOLUTIONS, ILLEGAL
MARIA: WELCOME BACK.
I’M BACK WITH TEXAS
CONGRESSWOMAN ELECT, MAYRA
FLORES.
LET ME GET YOUR TAKE WHAT
SOLUTIONS COULD BE.
WE HAVE SEEN ANOTHER RECORD
MONTH IN TERMS OF APPREHENSIONS
AT THE SOUTHERN BORDER.
YOU MENTIONED THE CHILD
TRAFFICKING.
WHAT DO YOU WANT TO SEE WITH
REGARD TO LEGAL IMMIGRATION?
>> WELL, I WANT TO IMPROVE THE
PROCESS.
YOU KNOW.
I DO BELIEVE IT IS OUTDATED.
WE NEED A PROCESS WHERE IT IS,
SAFER AND FASTER FOR THE GOOD
PEOPLE THAT WANT TO COME HERE TO
THE UNITED STATES AND WORK HARD
FOR THE AMERICAN DREAM.
I DO BELIEVE WE NEED TO FOCUS ON
LEGAL IMMIGRATION, NOT ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION ONLY FUNDING
CRIMINAL ORGANIZATIONS AND OF
COURSE INCREASING HUMAN
SMUGGLING AND HUMAN TRAFFICKING
AND ALSO CHILD TRAFFICKING AND
CHILDREN NO MATTER WHERE THEY’RE
FROM THEY NEED TO BE PRIORITY
KEEPING THEM SAFE.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IS NOT
DOING THAT.
MARIA: YEAH.
I MEAN AT THIS POINT,MAYRA, THE
DRUG CARTELS ARE TAKING HOME
$200 MILLION A WEEK.
THE CARTELS ARE RUNNING THE
BORDER OF AMERICA.
ALEJANDRO MAYORKAS SAYS THE
BORDER IS CLOSED IF YOU CAN
BELIEVE THAT.
JIM JORDAN WAS ON THIS PROGRAM A
COUPLE WEEKS AGO.
HE SAYS HE SHOULD BE IMPEACHED.
WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT KAMALA
HARRIS, THE VICE PRESIDENT IS
SUPPOSED TO BE THE BORDER CZAR?
>> THE VICE PRESIDENT IS USELESS
AND DO AGREE HE SHOULD BE
IMPEACHED.
HE IS ONLY LOOKING AFTER HIMSELF
AND THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IS
NOT LOOKING AFTER THE BORDER
PATROL AGENTS THAT ARE OUT THERE
EVERY SINGLE DAY RISKING THEIR
LIVES.
CONSTANTLY GETTING CRITICIZED BY
THIS ADMINISTRATION FOR
ENFORCING THE LAWS THAT THEY PUT
IN PLACE.
AND WE NEED TO GO, WE NEED TO
START ENFORCING THE LAWS THAT WE
ALREADY HAVE AND PUT BACK THE
POLICIES THAT THE PREVIOUS
ADMINISTRATION HAD THAT WERE
WORKING.
THAT IS THE REALITY.
UNDER TRUMP WE DID NOT HAVE THIS
BORDER CRISIS.
THAT’S A FACT.
WE DID NOT HAVE THIS INFLATION.
THAT IS A FACT.
AND WE NEED TO GO BACK TO THAT.
MARIA: REAL QUICK BEFORE YOU GO.
YOU WILL BE SWORN IN EARLY NEXT
WEEK.
THEN YOU HAVE TO DO THIS AGAIN
IN NOVEMBER.
HOW DO YOU FEEL ABOUT COMPETING
WITH THE DEMOCRAT IN THE
MIDTERMS?
>> WELL HONESTLY, IT MAKES NO
DIFFERENCE.
I’M VERY CONFIDENT IN THE WORK
THAT WE’RE DOING HERE IN SOUTH
TEXAS.
I’M VERY PROUD OF MY AMAZING
TEAM.
WE’RE GOING TO WIN THAT
RE-ELECTION THROUGH HARD WORK.